voilà un événement dans le monde de la
bande dessinée avec la sortie du dernier
album d'astérix le grand fossé il a été
inspiré à son auteur par la construction
du mur de berlin mais cette fois ci
c'est un village gaulois qui coupait en
deux j'ai bien dit son auteur car depuis
la disparation de rené goscinny astérix
n'a plus qu'un père albert uderzo
gérard holtz et ja grand gars verts
l'ont suivi leur passion albert uderzo
dessinateur signe particulier père
d'astérix gaulois petit mais
débrouillard et surtout amoureux fou
d'une très belle italienne finalement
albert uderzo ya deux passions dans
votre vie il ya le dessin et les ferrari
effectivement le tout de même un peu
plus sérieuse que l'autre nous en douter
un peu
mais l'affairé est tout de même
représente pour moi un rêve d'enfant
pour albert uderzo tout démarre vraiment
en 1951 lorsqu'il retrouve rené goscinny
entre les deux hommes c'est un vrai coup
de foudre ensuite il ya deux tournants
la création des pilotes nom prédestiné
et la naissance d'astérix
ensemble ils vont publier 24 albums qui
sont vendus écoutez bien à 100 millions
d'exemplaires
goscinny disparu en 1977 uderzo hésite
puis finalement décide de continuer à
faire vivre astérix en publiant son
nouvel album
il avoue s'être inspiré du mur de berlin
et je me suis dit pourquoi ce qui
n'existerait pas aller là sans gaulle
qui auraient des problèmes politiques
évidemment avec deux chefs qui veulent
chacun avoir l'intégrité du village mais
comme ils n'arrivent pas à se départager
ils sont obligés de scinder le village
en deux et au lieu de mettre à mur le
gmi un fossé d'où le titre le grand
fossé et astérix intervient bien sûr
bien entendu pour incommoder les deux
parties du globe
j'aurais dû les deux parties du village
mais ça se complique parce qu'il ya une
partie du village qui requiert l'aide
des romains et c'est pourquoi l'autre
partie du village va chercher le lot
d'astérix vous n'avez pas eu des
problèmes de conscience après la
disparition de rené goscinny
si évidemment bon mise à part si vous
voulez toute la partie affective et tout
ce drame que nous avons vécu à priori
pensait qu assurer que c'était était
fini et est mort cette osmose qui existe
entre de signer - pendant ces 26 années
dans laquelle nous avons travaillé me
permettait de croire que je connaissais
parfaitement le suivaient d'une part et
puis là quand la façon très particulière
qui avait négocié ni de penser de penser
bande dessinée de penser gag de bande
dessinée il ya une mécanique évidemment
est alors j'espère que j'en aurai
un dixième du talent pour arriver à un
résultat est-ce qu'on a aussi peur
lorsque sort un album d'astérix que
lorsque sort un livre une pièce de
théâtre ou un film
j'imagine que tous les créateurs ont ce
en ce moment d'angoissé évidemment au
moment où on met entre les mains du
public entre les mains des lecteurs
le produit de son imagination c'est de
sa création
vous avez peur que le ciel vous tombe
sur la tête alors ce soir on a toujours
peur que le ciel tombe sur la tête
m'enfin comme dit à ces rixes ça ne
pense pas que ça soit demain la veille